do this thing called unhelpful advice
going yeah unhelpful advice with Bobby
kalila and Andrew Santino hi Bobby Lee I
have a very unique and disturbing
problem a little background I work in a
fairly fairly large distribution company
on the west coast
it's a typical eight to five office job
I spend most of my time singing a desk
and a cubicle now to the problem I have
a co-worker who regularly beats his meet
in the bathroom stalls it's pretty
obvious when he's doing it
due to the shadows that are cast by the
overhead lights multiple people have
witnessed his bathroom special time and
have expressed displeasure with knowing
a grown man is pleasuring himself just
feet away while they are trying to take
a squat this is happening on a daily
basis HR seems like an unnecessary
Avenue to fixing this problem but
obviously this needs to stop so the
question is what do I do
can I feel this one anomaly what's the
name his name is Joe hey hey hey Joe
leave that [ __ ] guy alone he's
jerking off in the stall leave him alone
yeah
he needs that time yeah why are you why
first of all casting shadows are you
watching him he was hanging out he must
be timing his bathroom breaks to get in
there with unless this guy's jerking off
all day long in the bathroom yeah that's
a work problem then it's like dude you
got to get water you got to get work
done you've been jerking off for eight
hours but if this guy wants to take 15
minutes out of his day to go let some
[ __ ] stress out in the stall
not bothering anybody mind your business
Joe I mind your business Joe that's
crazy the first year I did comedy Fred
burns who's the manager Club I had to
come up to me and go I know what you're
doing before your shows yeah and it's
just a little weird you don't need to do
that your jerk you were jerking off yeah
in the greenroom no in the bathroom wait
in the public where other people were
you know I was in that stall what people
think of what I'm saying like you didn't
have a green room bathroom no that was
it that lawyer comments or there's no oh
yeah I would go to that bathroom in the
back yeah closest all intercom because I
had so much anxiety you had to get it
out I had to get it out and there was a
real thing yeah that I did yeah and then
one day while I was jerking off in there
I saw a drawing
Fred Burns the manager had drawn a
gigantic cartoon right of you know of a
man with Down syndrome molesting me as a
kid what he couldn't get hard yes did
you get harder no no he knew that you
Fred made a drawing free dog
I said don't don't do that don't do that
anymore right and then I though the
compute the boss there's no one to
complain of it you know so I stopped
doing it you know they were in the
privacy of your vast all right I find
literally nothing nothing wrong with it
either
you're not harassing somebody by the way
if he's jerking off at his desk bathroom
I do have a really close friend of mine
who happens to be just a really hyper
sexual he's [ __ ] his nuts are just
always so full of [ __ ] jizz yeah yeah
big jizz balls is a brace he needs to a
big Bobby could I use your bathroom
what's up Big B I want to go there for a
minute
I love your big BM president that's a
good god I'm with you on this one
Georgia yeah but this guy has to every
lunch break yeah yeah he has to it's
something that his body he's like I I
don't know what it is but it has to come
out and he just his dick is always hot
privacy of a stall yes yes I bother
anybody doesn't creep anybody out now is
this the other question of the follow-up
for this if the guys like listening to
porn or being weird and they're hmm I
get I get then it's like public nuisance
but if he's just quietly in there
the difference between someone pooping
he pooping it's a natural you got to get
it out this guy is now he's gotta check
it off he's not dude he's not involving
other people yeah Joe leave him alone
you do nothing and you and you stop
looking for shadows I think he's trying
to put it off you know what you know
what this sounds like this sounds like
he doesn't really think it's that weird
and he might want to do it but he's
asking what if they got a shadow puppet
like a master or something if he made
shadow puppets with his [ __ ] would be
hilarious by the way but I worked an
office job I jerked off in the stall I
mean not often but I had to I had to a
couple of times in fact yeah yeah I had
a mint I remember I remember very
vividly having a midday I was like god
I'm so [ __ ] horny and I went in the
bathroom and as I was sitting on the
stall I was like am I gonna am I really
gonna do this
yeah the matrix the red pill or the blue
pill yeah and so I jumped into the
toilet I flush myself down like
Trainspotting no but I did i sat there
and I thought God is this was gonna be
this gross I thought is this gross I was
in the stall I was by myself do you
flush to mask the sound of your yes
coming yeah are you allowed you know how
people flush when they're as they're
[ __ ] that's what I do while I push
so that there is no plop and also it's
actually courtesy flush you're like
pooping into a waterfall yeah the smell
it doesn't linger there yeah you just
got it I think is the most respectable
way - it really is I close the lid and
poop on it and then I leave it open so
people get in there like what is this my
dad caught me masturbating I tell you
that story because in my parents bad
bathroom the faucet in their bathtub is
so hot you like it's so strong so you're
putting it on your so I would stick my
dick on it and I would jerk off like up
on my knees I'm upright like this with
the with the water rushing gushing down
right and and I turn around and my dad's
there no and he goes like this he goes
walk into the [ __ ] never never talked
about it a long time he had this like a
man I'll call like that and we never
said it but a village yeah yeah villain
well that was a great um you know thing
thank you for that don't say nothing
don't say don't say nothing so whiskey
ginger
[Music]